[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
pâques nous allons parler de la
situation politique de ce qui se passe à
gauche de ce qui se passe du côté des
macros nist de ce qui ne se passe pas du
côté de du rassemblement national et
puis nous allons aborder évidemment la
question des législatives s'agit-il d'un
au troisième tour avec un parfum de
revanche comme le dit jean luc mélenchon
sa victime d'une confirmation de ce qui
s'est passé aux présidentielles pour en
parler véronique jérôme beaujour sur 10
vous êtes maître de conférences en
sciences de gestion à l'université paris
saclay vous êtes créatrice est
responsable d'un du site élections scop
qui fait des prévisions scientifiques
assurent les cofondatrices cofondatrice
absolument et vous aviez prévu
d'ailleurs je rappelle au mois de
janvier que emmanuel macron serait réglé
avec 58,6 % des voix ce qu'était
exactement le le score
merci
raphaël mata duvignau bonjour maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université
par de versailles sont comptables us qu
est membre a aussi des surligneurs
il ya il a dès hier
une intervention toute récente
du fondateur des salinières sur l'europe
qui est très intéressant on peut
l'opposition désobéissance européenne
absolument jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour vous êtes éditeur toujours jouer
l'éditeur heureux envers avoir un prix
pour un livre très bien donc on est ravi
nicolas landry bonjour est journaliste à
tv 78 et puis on accueille sébastien
ramage bonjour et félicitations parce
que vous êtes le candidat
nubes null null null psc pour l'union
populaire écolo écologique et sociale
dans la première circonscription des
yvelines c'est à dire celle qui sait
faire ça et c'est billy montigny
guyancourt en gros c'est ça donc on va
parler de cette succession va commencer
évidemment pas parler de ce qui se passe
à gauche est ce que c'est le retour de
l'union delà de la gauche c'est vrai
qu'on d'énergie cette émission 7 10 mai
cédé nniversaire de la victoire de
françois mitterrand
est ce que est ce que jean luc mélenchon
c'est le nouveau françois mitterrand je
commencerai par vous alors je ne ferai
pas des comparaisons hasardeuses période
de l'histoire et est différente il ya eu
une vague au chili la gauche plurielle
aujourd'hui la nouvelle union populaire
ce qu'il faut ce qui va peut-être
différencier notre union populaire c'est
le la radicalité du programme et sa
pertinence pour répondre aux problèmes
concrets des français
ce n'est pas une coalition simplement de
partis de gauche c'est une coalition
autour d'un programme et avec un
débouché mélenchon premier ministre à la
fin des élections donc c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement mobilisateur pour un
électorat de gauche qui nous est déjà
envoyé un message à la présidentielle
qui voulait que nous soyons à la fois
unis mais surtout que nous faisions
autour de base programmatique qui change
le quotidien et ce qui change par
rapport à ce qui s'était passé en 2017
ou finalement on avait reproché
dégageant le groupe a profité de son bon
score il avait plus de pratiquement 20 %
1 au premier tour des présidentielles et
il l'aurait pu se retrouver hors ou
fausses j'allais au centre de la gauche
voit comme leader de la gauche il avait
passé 17 cette occasion la la il le fait
alors je sais pas si on peut reprocher à
la personne qui a fait le plus grand
score et qui a rassemblé le plus de
lecteurs et des lectrices d'être la
personne qui rassemble le moins le fait
est qu'aujourd'hui on a fait la
démonstration que voilà le ya une
appétence dans le peuple de gauche mais
au-delà de ça chez les abstentionnistes
pour notre programme maintenant c'est
autour de ces bases là que toute la
réorganisation de notre camp se fait
donc en avant voilà
directement et bien si vous regardez les
sondages d'opinion par exemple nous
sommes passés de 10 7% dans les sondages
la veille de l'élection du premier tour
à 22% dans les urnes c'est bien que ce
qu'on peut dire c'est bien que quelque
part il ya des gens qui n'étaient pas
certains d'aller voter s'ils ont fini
par aller voter pour nous et puis offert
voted appelé au christ au caisson qui
est devenu qui voulaient voter hidalgo
ouvert et qui ont pour ses ovules et
sondages ont influencé par le sauvage
que le vote utile c'était le vote mais
non je l'y ai peut-être ça aussi comme
moi comme vous les électeurs et
électrices sont des personnes
rationnelles qui sont capables à la fois
de mettre en corrélation d'un côté les
idées et de l'autre côté la stratégie
pour faire avancer ses idées en tant que
politique on est obligé de proposer des
stratégies victorieuse et des programmes
des programmes qui répondent aux
aspirations c'est le croisement des deux
qui fait qu'on a aujourd'hui la nuque
est donc le nouvel hymne populaire juste
une question par rapport à cette union
est son origine
nous on a interrogé des personnes avant
le premier tour des des électeurs peut
être de gauche qui justement ne
souhaitait pas voter pour un candidat de
gauche mais plutôt s'abstenir ou voter
blanc parce que y'avait pas d'union donc
ma question est simple est-ce que
l'origine c'est le fait qu'ils aient eu
des critiques sur le fait qu'ils aient
pas eu un candidat unique de la gauche à
la présidentielle et la deuxième
question aussi sait comment ça s'est
fait au niveau local parce que dans les
yvelines comment vous échangé entre les
différents mouvements de gauche ont dans
le département alors je pense que les
personnes qui vous ont tenu ce disque au
final on s'en doute sont sans doute
aller voter sinon le score de jean luc
mélenchon elle ne serait pas à la
hauteur qu'il est pour rappel nous
sommes à 400 mille voix du second tour
alors qu'on nous attendait une défaite
historique de la gauche voire sa
disparition pour les années à venir là
on est parvenu à refaire des scores
comparables à ce que notre camp a pu
faire
dans ces 60 dernières années quand même
aussi vous méfier d'une chose c'est que
vous êtes tous très enthousiastes et et
tant mieux pour vous je il faut cet
enthousiasme mais on se rappelle du
score des écologistes ou municipales
c'était merveilleux c'était le nouveau
grand parti c'était allait tout balayer
etc et puis comme consultant
mécontent de chances d'élection on
s'aperçoit que le voc soi disant super
écolo serra qui font ce qu'ils font
pourtant la principale solution aussi
bien qu'il n'ait pas le même à une
élection présidentielle mi temps les
deuxième poteau anticipation des
élections présidentielles qui est bien
plus représentative je pense de l'état
de l'opinion que ne peuvent être des
scrutins intermédiaires heroes où il ya
un taux de participer de détention
dignes abyssal bloquent notamment les
municipales à cause de routes de la
classique vite vers des législatives
avec l' élection comme député de
monsieur mélenchon à marseille avec 66 %
d'abstention de
justement qu elle va s
quand on écoute sébastien ramage donc
un défi c'est formidable parce que
vous reprenez ce discours comme quoi
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a gagné la
présidentielle quand même ça c'est très
fort de sa part oui sur le plan
d'ailleurs vous parler de stratégie il
ya vraiment une stratégie qui est pour
l'heure assez efficace puisque ça buzz
et sur les médias on a parlé de jean luc
mélenchon plus que n'importe quelle
autre d'ailleurs certains certains
stratèges notamment à en marche enfin je
ne devrais plus dire en marche devrait
dès renaissance
ensemble considère que finalement vous
faites la campagne pour eux parce que et
on pourrait presque être d'accord avec
vous je provoque un jeu était très
provocatrice mais ce qu'on pourrait dire
si je regarde l'union il ya toujours un
problème avec les unions sont fait un
parallèle avec l'économie les cartes
elles conduisent toujours à des
dissidences les cartels toujours à ce
que des free riders sorte parce qu'ils
voient un intérêt particulier plus
important que l'intérêt général et ça
c'est une possibilité qui est ouverte
chacun d'eux se dit mais j'ai intérêt
dès qu'il ya un avantage à sortir de
l'union que le pense il sort mais ce
faisant il fait capoter d'union et c'est
ce qu'on commence à voir les fissures
que l'on voit actuellement lorsqu'il ya
certains cas quand même où visiblement
il n'a parlera peut-être la 15e
circonscription à paris pose problème
mais quand on entend juste voilà qui
soutient l'union tout en soutenant un
candidat qui n'est pas investi on voit
bien qu'ils aient des intérêts que
l'intérêt individuel disputé à l'intérêt
général et donc les risques de
dissidence sont avérés après il faudra
voir les conditions de la dissidence
parce que le financement des candidats
dissidents peut être finalement un
problème mais cette union elle est faite
autour de jean luc mélenchon mais pas
autour du centre puisqu'il n'ya pas une
forme de radicalité et peut-être que ce
ce côté des centres et de l'union qui se
fait autour de jean luc mélenchon va
poser problème à certains électeurs et
je ne permettrai pas de parler à la
place des actes des électeurs mais je
dis quand même que si on observe le
passé la condition d'accès aux 2 ou
seconds tours étant de douze ennemis et
oui le jeu serait inscrit ce qui courent
un taux de 52 % d'abstention 48 % de
participation comme à peu près en
moyenne la dernière fois il faut avoir
26 % des exprimés 26 % des exprimés donc
là ça posera ça posera un problème mais
voilà je je je m'interroge sur les
conditions de l'union qui pourraient
peut-être être une incitation à
l'abstention d'un électeur qui va
considérer que finalement effectivement
vous êtes réunis vous appeler au vote
utile pour maximiser les voies mais là
encore les lecteurs va peut-être
comprendre votre stratégie vous avez
raison il est de moins en moins me up il
va voir que l'objectif c'est pour le
candidat arrivé à gagner l'élection peut
pas lui reprocher mais après après se
pose la question du programme et la
communauté de programmes pour ne pas
dire le programme commun parce que ça
peut faire référence
il ya une référence au programme commun
et aussi des références au front
populaire donc à pitre où ce peuple à
ces choses là les lecteurs à être perdus
ne sera pas exactement pourquoi il va
voter ne sera peut-être pas en accord
avec ce programme et il va se poser la
question de savoir est ce que je vote
pour finalement des convictions qui sont
un second choix ou est-ce que mon choix
n'étant pas respectée et bien je vais
m'abstenir donc l'abstention est le vrai
je dirais la vraie
affaire
c'est c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir il
ya un appel forcément à gauche cela dans
une situation où la gauche était plutôt
dans une sorte de marasme et où jean luc
mélenchon en a
retourné des cibles des choses et
retourner les choses en sa faveur il
peut y avoir en effet un ellos d'isobar
on n'est pas fichu totalement
c'est le sait la force de jean luc
mélenchon qui est charismatique qui est
je vais employer le mot qui est grande
gueule et qui n'hésite pas à mettre les
pieds dans le plat et finalement je
pense que la force de jean-luc mélenchon
et la force de la france insoumise c'est
justement de faire converger c'est ce
qu'on voudrait dire une dernière fois
une fois précédentes faire converger
certaine colère une colère une
défiance une frustration aussi de la
part des électeurs et des citoyens et je
pense que il arrive à faire converger
ces éléments maintenant est-ce que le
vote mélenchon est un vote d'adhésion je
n'en suis pas certain je ne suis pas
spécialiste de l'opinion politique je ne
suis pas spécialiste de sciences
politiques mais je ne suis pas certain
encore une fois que le vote mélenchon
soit 1,22 au présidentielles au
programme il ya une party girl donné
lieu une partie ils forceront caire vote
utile aux comores absolument et moi ce
qui me ce qui m'interpelle c'est la
rapidité avec laquelle le ps et le pc
les écologistes se sont regroupés
derrière mélenchon alors vous parliez
d'un programme de travail mais ça a
quand même été fait cette coalition
était fait en quelques jours et donc
contrairement à ce qui a pu se passer
avant avec un vrai travail en amant de
préparation d'un véritable programme de
gouvernement et là j'ai quand même
l'impression que les que le ps et le
léser les communistes d'une certaine
manière en trouver si vous voulez refuge
chez la france a soumises pour des
questions ans on en parlera peut-être
après pour des questions on va dire de
circonscription électoraliste m'étonne
on le voit déjà on le voit déjà vous
avez raison absolument sûr les sur le
programme sur les sur le fond il ya déjà
les divergences et donc finalement les
électeurs traditionnels communistes ou
socialistes voire écologistes ne se
retrouveront peut-être pas dans le
programme qui a été je provoque aussi
fortement imposés par jean luc mélenchon
et donc il y aura lundi regardent
peut-être aussi on va le round 2 % oui
c'est l'hiver wifi gloria mundi fois
plus que que idéalement mais les
électeurs socialistes ne se retrouveront
ne se retrouvent pas dormi on va parler
de programme mais il ya une question qui
intéresse en tout faux si vous faisiez
allusion
au programme de la gauche de la gauche
et au programme commun et qui si on
reprend les mesures et programmes
communs il y avait baisse de l'âge de la
retraite il y avait blocage des prix il
y avait ce qu'on retrouve à deux trois
ou quatre mesures pour retrouve dans le
programme aujourd'hui et ça a été 80 et
puis une tournante 83 et la conversion
de la gauche a à la
une technique de gouvernement à devenir
un parti gouvernemental un parti de
pouvoir c'est cette conversion
d'ailleurs que de la gauche à sa qui
explique probablement la défaite du
parti socialiste mais il ya deux
possibilités est ce que c'est la gauche
socialiste les écolos qui se
convertissent à une la gauche 2-2 de
mélenchon qui est une gauche radicale ou
est-ce que c'est jean luc mélenchon qui
se convertit à une culture de
gouvernement qui revient aux
fondamentaux de notre camp je pense
qu'on est là sainement avec ces grands
moments de l'histoire où les droits des
français les françaises vont faire des
bonds en avant considérable parce que
ils auront mis à la tête des programmes
de rupture tout simplement donc nous on
s'inscrit là dedans vous parlez du
tournant de la rigueur je pense que ce
qui différencie aussi ce qu'on a créé
aujourd'hui c'est le rapport au
mouvement social et aux luttes
syndicales vous retrouver dans l'union
populaire l'ensemble de ces combats là
et je voulais réagir à ce que vous
disiez je partage parfaitement l'analyse
intérêt général intérêt particulier
quand il s'agit des dissidents du parti
socialiste je pense notamment
majoritairement je pense que cette
période est aussi une clarification d'un
certain nombre de
compromission voire de trahison qui ont
été faites par la gauche dit c'est plus
le cas on voit aujourd'hui que leur
score de gouvernement que ce soit
françois hollande que ce soit voilà un
certain nombre de bernard cazeneuve de
décompresser d'accord le duo ps bon si
vous regardez un peu ce que dit olivier
faur aujourd'hui l'adhésion du parti
socialiste à cette union populaire elle
est aussi programmatique et c'est une
remise en question d'un certain nombre
de renoncement que la gauche
social-démocrate a pu faire ces
dernières années donc la convergence je
vous en dis quelques-unes ses 60 ans la
retraite voilà est-ce que vous avez
alors que alors que alors que la gauche
socialiste avait allongé le la durée de
travail mais ce qui va à rebours dans le
combat historique jeudi à la sécurité
sociale cédé 3,60 euros parce que
toulouse 10 la retraite à 60 ans slogan
formidable mais vous dites il faut 40
ans d'annuités de travail c'est à dire
que quelqu'un qui commence à travailler
à 25 ans il prendra sa retraite à 65 ans
bien qu il ya un calcul proportionnel
qui se fait en fonction du nombre
d'années ce qui est important c'est de
re de travailler et de cotiser ce qui
est important c'est de retirer la décote
parce que quand vous dites retraite à 65
ans si vous partez avant vous avez une
décote qui vous fait une double peine
parce qu'à la fois vous n'avez pas le
nombre de cotisations
tout ça déconcerte que les gens qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans autre
élément c'est que c'est une première
étape effectivement nous sommes sûrs
retraite à 60 ans c'est le discours
public vous doutez bien que avec ce
qu'on tient comme ligne et avec la
manière dont nous allons gérer le pays
évidemment la perspective de revenir à
37 ans et demi c'est une perspective
même pas de long terme de moyen terme
que nous nous fixions mais pour
l'instant retraite à 37 3 ans et demi
d'être garantie voilà c'était l'objectif
comme c'était le cas auparavant mais là
actuellement ce qui est dans notre
programme et ce sur quoi nous nous
sommes mis d'accord c'est 60 ans 41
annuités donc pas de recul mais surtout
une avancée par rapport à ce qui a été
fait c'est dire dix dernières années
verdict et sur les traités européens par
contre je note que d'emblée olivier faur
obtenu quelques aménagements puisqu'on
express
3 trois dossiers qui la retraite il ne
fait pas la retraite ils ont accepté et
puis il ya en effet la désobéissance sur
les traités européens que prône des
défis
et les aménagements que demandent
comment associer les sabres au sort et
on voit qu a quand même eu quelques
éléments enfin on imagine difficilement
que les choses pourraient être actés et
que les électeurs vont donner un
blanc-seing ce programme alors je feins
je sais pas c'est une c'est peut-être un
jugement de valeur pourriez vous dire
mais on voit bien qu'il ya des tensions
de tous les côtés en annonçant fin on
entend que carole delga on entend si
françois hollande on ne sait pas si
lorsqu'ils pensent on le sait à peu près
on ne sait pas s'il va se présenter ou
pas il a encore il encore dit joël pour
eux pour le dire mais on sent bien que
des anciens frondeurs socialiste comme
bernard cazeneuve par exemple sont vent
debout ont
envie de lancer quelque chose donc vous
fait pas non plus l'unanimité
cette union de toutes les gauches n'est
pas né n'est pas réalisée il me semble
que là envisager la probabilité d'une
cohabitation et de jean luc mélenchon
premier ministre ça sent quand même
hautement
probable
c'est un progrès mais alors là c'est la
question c'est de savoir qui dominera
l'opposition au fond c est ce que ça
sera le rassemblement justement où là il
me semble que juste pour terminer il me
semble que il ya une chose qu'on ne voit
pas ici et la droite est très fin très
silencieuse alors qu'elle pourrait très
bien jouer le pivot dans cette élection
parce que finalement tout le monde
essaye de s'unir les unions pose
problème alors il ya la droite nationale
qui n'arrivent pas à s'unir mais je
parle de la droite je dirais
républicaines sont peu la bbc de l ère
pour l heure il ya peut-être la
possibilité de jouer un peu ce parti
charnière à l'image du parti libéral en
allemagne c'est à dire que c'est la
force d'appoint dont on aura besoin
peut-être la majorité présidentielle
similaire pour être une force d'appoint
et ça pourrait être quelque chose de
beaucoup plus je dirais en cohérence
avec l'idéologie je parle pas de deux
avis bien évidemment et ça pourrait être
plus en cohérence avec des les
rencontres et les convergences
idéologiques que finalement ce que ce
que vous essayez proposées dont on
imagine alors pour l'instant vous pouvez
vous fonder sur des sondages mais n'y a
que deux sondages qui donnent finalement
à pratiquement égale répartition presque
un tiers à chaque grand mouvement alors
la droite est mise avec le centre et
l'est rémy avec le centre met en place
le elle est fille en premier frein voilà
ce qu'il faudrait quand même rappeler
enfin c'est ce que vous allez lire
d'oublier c'est que mélenchon est
arrivée troisième il n'est pas arrivé là
neuvième essai la liste très fermée
dexant mais c'est très fort il faut
arrêter l'évasion mais il faut de temps
en temps remettre le mée célérité
des gens s'était planté pendant deux
tours qui s'est fait un troisième tour
pour réussir ce risque d'un slogan
formidable avis ce refus de la
démocratie en dix ans le président macro
ont été mal élu fait les mauvaises
élections ça serait les territoires
qui sont ils et dans les territoires je
voulais venir pharma juste sur le
principe je viens deux d'être là à dire
on a quasiment gagné l'expo non vous
êtes arrivé troisième à voilà troisièmes
c'est pas second c'est la démocratie est
ainsi faite que droite est restée
initiation
différents pavie la douche c'est ça
peut-être que vous dites finalement
c'est une addition additionnant les
messieurs mais maintenant on en
additionnant les différents candidats de
droite arrive on l'a vu tomber si vous
fait ses calculs si vous additionnez les
carreaux les poireaux ok on peut faire
peut-être une soupe probablement
indigeste mais ça n'a donc selon vous
marine le pen se veut gagner l'élection
présidentielle absolument absolument non
mais parce que si on additionne le
signifier que vous qui parlez
d'additionner des choses qui ne sont en
aucun cas additional voilà c'est au 25 m
ce que vous disiez je souhaite enfin
pour la démocratie serait très bien que
les sociaux démocrates de gauche relève
le nez et sorte de 7,2 ce gloubiboulga
yves idéologique que hollande pour qui
mais pourtant je n'ai pas une passion
mes collants 15,9 le foll va tous ces
gens là se bouge un peu carole delga etc
il ya un espace pour eux un espace
intellectuel il a qui sont des gens qui
ont parfois comme carole delga des
territoires je suis donc d'assurer leur
motif il faudrait pas oublier centre
cette fois un tweet du président du prg
qui s'appelle guillaume lacroix pas très
connu guillaume lacroix me voilà aimé ça
dit bien là là les dissensions qu'il
peut y avoir
bush et alors il dit donc bateau pour
être crédible sur un projet social de
gauche il faut être pro burqini pro-ours
va raconter quilles et qui sait
pro-russe aux pros caron et bien tant
pis je préfère rester crédible sur le
projet républicain seul projet social
qui puisse véritablement changé d'avis
durablement
alors
frau burqini il faut ça fait référence à
ce qui se passe à grenoble chez eric
piolle qui a qui permet
l'ouverture d'aider des piscines aux
femmes en burqini ça vous ça vous gêne
ça ou ça vous soutenez ça
je n'ai pas vocation à sur ce plateau à
refaire non car j'ai vu mon nom mais
c'est l autorise la loi
oui parce que je pense qu'il ya une
grosse partie de l'opinion publique qui
est de parlons des médias qui sont
absolument arc bouté sur les questions
liées à l'islam on voit bien qu'il ya
des objectifs politiques derrière de la
part notamment de 25 ans qui s'appelle
l'extrême droite et même la droite de
monsieur macro si malheureusement il
faut monter ces sujets triste un criant
allah akhbar détendu à côté de gens qui
aiment et qui criaient allah akbar dans
les manifestations c'est vrai que là
c'est un engagement vis à vis de l'islam
qui est
assez couru deuxièmement vous vous
parlez de la loi il ya une loi qui gère
les
les tenues dans les piscines dans la loi
l'autorisé sinon il n'y a pas tant ce
que vient pas de loi on n'a pas le droit
dans une piscine vide y aller avec un
boxeur normalement parce que c'est pas
une considéré comme quelque chose de
propre renseigne la loi renseignez vous
savez ce sont des maillots de bain oui
si vous autorisez dans l'hémicycle
quantité de tissus non mais ne parlait
pas de loi la loi ne fixe pas la
quantité difficile c'est factuel débat
qui n'a pas de louer la laïcité il n'y a
pas lésiné sur les piscines
justement parce que l'état l'état ne
régit pas la religion des terminaux et
juste pour dire qu'il y est mais ça fait
partie de ce que disaient les jambes
c'est à dire qu'il peut aussi y avoir
des dits sociaux il ya évidemment vous
faites un accord donc chacun vient de
chez lui on n'est pas forcément vous
n'êtes pas forcément tous d'accord sur
les mêmes sur les mêmes critères alors
ya la candidature de ouaf
ouaf qui est eux qui devaient se
présenter avait dit cieux qui finalement
renoncent
alors ce qui se passe autour de la
candidature de monsieur boivent je pense
que cela doit sérieusement interrogé à
la fois notre démocratie l'état dans
laquelle se trouve et notre système
médiatique monsieur vous ave n'a pas eu
le droit à la réponse une seule fo pa
installeur exergue leurs invités il est
à dire qu' il était mandaté par une
instance mais jamais avec nous et il
fait appel donc pour l'instant il est
deuxième élément c'est la présomption
d'innocence a en main en épingle au
final une petite affaire mais il n'ya
pas que ça derrière monsieur goiffon du
ressort tous ces tweets où il ressort la
moindre prise de position publique je ne
connais pas de personnalité publique à
qui on accorde ce même traitement demain
sur ce plateau ou sur d'autres plateaux
il ya des fascistes qui vont
tranquillement se balader et dire qu'il
ya un grand remplacement en france dire
qu' il faudrait laisser les gens mourir
en méditerranée qu'il faudrait des
traitements différenciés dans la
sécurité sociale ou par en fonction 2001
de la nationalité le front national
l'extrême droite zemmour east dans ses
ressources
sur monsieur oif dixon a aussi levé aux
longues années on n'essaye pas de
l'attendait attendait mais encore une
fois remettons les choses à leur place
monsieur oif n'a jamais eu accès à un
seul plateau télé le score alors que
l'extrême droite parade sur l'ensemble
des patoisants même les chaînes est ce
que c'est juste répondre à la question
quels sont les tweets de bois fait
qu'est ce qu'on reproche à voir ce que
vous et plan d'attaqué l'extrême droite
très bien mais est-ce qu'on peut parler
de doivent alors monsieur bois fait un
militant antiraciste et je pense que
aussi on doit s'interroger sur une
société qui met sur le même niveau des
gens qui ont subi le racisme toute leur
vie parce que c'est le cas de monsieur
grafe et qui se bat contre les
discriminations dont lui est incertain
d'autres nombre de gens font pas font
qu'on subisse on met sur le même niveau
bof et des militants de l'extrême droite
qui sera pas encore professionnalisme
qui sont suprémaciste blanc pour
certains et qui paradent tranquillement
sur les plateaux télé donc oui il ya un
problème à régler notre système
démocratique vite noté les progrès sont
un peu les velléités ses propos des
propos de bernard mais on va bénéficier
aux bois simplement nos sections le
symbole c'est important parce que on
peut considérer de deux façons soit le
le lui donner une investiture était une
sorte de provocation soit c'était de
montrer que des gens des quartiers
peuvent aussi accéder à une fonction
politique c'est la deuxième pourquoi
pourquoi ça serait une provocation c'est
mauvais ça regardez regardez ce que
disait ce matin bois sera pas candidat
blais big lots de solde nul est
irremplaçable pour le coup si monsieur
bois fils est irremplaçable citez moi un
seul jeune de quartier de 25 ans qui a
une visibilité d'état scio visibilité
nationale en politique y'en a pas c'est
à dire que il ya toute une partie de la
population qui avec un porte parole ce
les propos est ce que disait monsieur
oif qui aujourd'hui se retrouve sans
représentant moi je trouve qu'il ya des
quand même en premier que le tracé pour
injure ça va je trouve triste
je trouve triste que notre assemblée
nationale n'est pas un seul ouvriers
d'une usine dans ses rangs qu'il n'y ait
pas un seul jeunes issus des quartiers
populaires peut-être qu'il serait temps
qu'on remette en cause qui sont nos
représentants
et la représentativité nos institutions
on essaye avec la nouvelle union
populaire de changer il ya eu aussi la
fausse rumeur sur le sur mesure un décès
lors des manifestations à tolbiac
écoutez moi je vais pas réagir à la au
moindre jeu derrière miami chad ho kelly
sur un plateau télé que zemmour était
injuste de service est ce que on est en
train de débattre de ça aujourd'hui
et c'est un robot avec savard avait
prêté une policière des fours des les
policiers de d'arabe de service 7 aces à
ce qu'on lui reprochait alors je sais
pas si vous avez vu monsieur bouafi les
arabes aux siens le feu d'origine
maghrébine mais voilà donc le traité lui
de raciste
je précise t elle c était précédée pour
éclairer les les ensuite c'est une
référence évidente je veux dire on est
tous cultivés ici monsieur malcom x qui
parlait des noirs de deux chambres dans
les dans les champs de coton je veux
dire il ya une référence évidente ça ce
sont des propos qui dans le mouvement
antiraciste se comprennent en fait ce
sont des comparaisons historiques qui
sont rationnels qui sont basés sur voilà
sur sur notre sur l'histoire des
discriminations dans les pays européens
et aux états unis donc mais je vous
comprendrez que pour des gens qui
étaient fort de
la gauche plus traditionnelles qui
défendent la laïcité ça peut comme com
lacroix ou comme des gens qui viennent
du parti socialiste ça peut poser des
problèmes
c'est une des questions c'est d'une des
questions je dire ce que que souligner
que jérôme total se dire que dans cette
alliance il ya quand même une domination
de la fissure sur les autres parties
comme vous dites et après tout mélenchon
a fait beaucoup plus que les autres mais
qui peut en effet posé un certain nombre
de problèmes à des gens de l'espèce vie
ou du père c'est la question c'est
est-ce que tout s'est fait au niveau
national ou est ce que justement la
question genre en vient à la question
que vous posez au début est ce que au
niveau local comment ça s'est passé au
niveau local et ce qui a eu des débats
est ce qu'il ya des désaccords de fond
sur des sujets qui peuvent être locaux
parce que vous rappeler que les
législatives certes c'est un scrutin
national mais ça se passe dans les
territoires donc est ce que finalement
comment ça s'est passé dans les yvelines
alors vous vous doutez bien que en deux
semaines de négociations régler le cas
de
577 circonscriptions
ça n'a pas permis beaucoup
d'allers-retours locaux il ya des
déceptions évidemment il ya des gens qui
ont dû renoncer à leur candidature dans
l'ensemble de nos parties ici au niveau
local on a eu
dernière fois hier soir une discussion
sur comment mener campagne ensemble on
est sur une bannière une étiquette
commune maintenant c'est ça l'objectif
moi en tout cas je m'engage à défendre
avec la même force et la même vigueur ma
candidature ou celle du parti socialiste
sur la seat 7e circonscription des
yvelines celle de génération sur laon la
8e circonscription des yvelines parce
que nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur un
programme monsieur lacroix vous vous
affichez son tweet tout à l'heure ce qui
le sépare de la gauche je pense que
c'est les questions fondamentales de la
gauche en vérité est ce qu on est pour
ou contre la répartition des richesses
dans notre pays est-ce qu on est pour ou
contre le financement à hauteur des
besoins de nos services publics est-ce
qu on est pour ou contre les réformes
institutionnelles il sauver la
planification écologique le nucléaire
par exemple il ya débat n'a pas abordé
il est pas abordé dans l'accord donc
comme un certain nombre de grandes
questions été tranché le nucléaire notre
position elle est connue si nous
arrivons nous à faire nous proposerons
un référendum sur la question du
nucléaire et nous défendrons la sortie
du nucléaire
ce qui nous différencie du parti
communiste français voilà mais on a été
capable de se mettre d'accord sur
l'essentiel qui fâchent et parce que
c'est pas tant que c'est un sujet qui
fait avant parce que avec le parti
communiste français nous partageons
quand même une chose en commun sur la
question nucléaire c'est le retour d'un
acteur unique c'est-à-dire l'edf l'état
dans la dans la distribution la vente du
de l'électricité en france un grand
service public de l'énergie et ça c'est
quand même le débat je pense c'est plus
chaud du nucléaire ou pas de nucléaire
avec la pense que le nucléaire est bien
plus en sécurité par le lieu qui n'est
qu'un wc séparé mélenchon deux roues
seul nucléaire et bien peut être répétée
en france avec un pôle public de
l'énergie et des fonctionnaires qui
travaillent à son entretien qu avec des
boîtes d'intérim qui nettoie des
réacteurs nucléaires avec des gens qui y
travaillent mélenchon ne plus contrôler
divers si je comprends bien mais aussi
pour que ce soit bien je vais rien vous
dire la position défendront un
référendum avec la position de la sortie
du nucléaire ça c'est du structurel ça
est-ce que vous annoncez remettre d'en
haut dans le service public des éléments
essentiels comme l'énergie tout le monde
peut être d'accord en considérant que
c'est à l'état de gérer les ressources
pas d'accord on peut imaginer que du
point de vue d'une économie publique
c'est à l'état de gérer des ressources
comme l'énergie pour en imaginer la
meilleure affectation possible sauf que
ça ça ne se fait pas à très court terme
si vous voulez changer les modes de
répartition à court terme ça va ça
impossible et de surcroît sous l'école
vous interrogez de sur une chose c'est
vous parler des candidatures mais
jean-luc mélenchon n'est pas candidat
est ce que ce n'est pas un effet de
contre exemple enfin quand le élisez moi
à présent elle ne veut premier ministre
mais je ne présente pas quoi moi j'ai
cru comprendre c'était pour des
questions de transport que c'est
peut-être aussi parce que l'accès y
penser qu'ils n'avaient pas gagné mais
et
il est trop vieux pointe
visaient pas des
députés il est trouvé
mettez vous un temps la place de
l'électeur c'est à dire que les lecteurs
et il a envie de croire mais celui qui
lui fait passer le message il
est crédible c'est l'élection qui la
facem chantant des chansons chômage avec
100 électeurs attendaient ya eu dans
l'histoire de la vème biblique comme
vient de réduire monsieur des gens
n'étaient pas mal ça il y en a toujours
eu je suis satisfait sa campagne sur
élisez moi le premier je viens de le
cueillir cette mairie donc solide au
ministre belge en présence et je pense
qu'il a acquises comme elle qu'un but
retraite à 60 ans tout de suite pour
tout le monde mais lui il a soixante dix
ans donc
peut-être un mot sur ce qui se passe
dans les yvelines vous donc dans cette
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale il y aura huit sur les douze
circonscriptions huit candidats elle fit
trois génération écologie ou génération
c'est de pratiquer des dérivés du ps est
un socialiste d'ailleurs ces affiches et
les yvelines par circonscription et les
parties en saison
il ya des circonscriptions en effet ou
alors pour lever ou jean luc mélenchon a
fait des très bons scores
dans la huitième notamment il fait 54 %
à mantes-la-jolie
43% à mantes la ville mais avec un rn
qui est fort et macro detec 18% 43% à
limay ma crevette à -2 19% et si on
prend les mêmes les résultats par
circonscription par exemple seyant au
prince était là la huitième 8e dans la
circonscription circonscription 8 donc
l'ensemble des villes de la circo et
bien jean luc mélenchon est à 37 9 %
emmanuel macron est à 21,32 au coude à
coude avec marine le pen à 20 57 % et on
retrouve plusieurs circonscriptions dans
ce cas de figure aux jambes
11e aussi où il ya la verrière y attrape
70% et à l'échelle de la circonscription
il à
33,05 % contre 28 76 % pour les manuels
marchesa et les devants et la 7e où il
ya chanteloup les vignes et houda dia et
la mise de la ville va se présenter
surtout il fait 50,7 à melon ils
arrivent en tête aussi et à l'échelle de
la circonscription et bien en fait c'est
emmanuel macron qui arrivent néanmoins
en tête à 32 0 4% alors que jean luc
mélenchon est à 24 77 % marine le pen
arrive en troisième position à 15,93 %
et la 7e qui est la
circonscription classique du ps était
celle de michel rocard à conflans sainte
honorine vous espérez des victoires dans
ce département dans le département oui
et vouziers dans le premier
cas également de table qui visite
commentée cela globalement au niveau
national les projections sont très
bonnes et nous nous nous fixons comme
objectif et nous disons aux électeurs
électrices qu' il y a une vraie
possibilité de gagner vous avez été déçu
par le score du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et par ici les
gens ont envie
d'acheter des suspects seraient plantés
comme d'autres a priori des gens qui ont
voté pour nous oui c'est le trio second
tour a priori l'énorme taux d'abstention
au second du pc une certaine déception
moi par exemple je le dis sur ce plateau
j'ai voté emmanuel macron au second tour
parce que j'étais déterminé à faire
barrage aux idées de marine le pen bon
c'est par exemple d'aller alors c'est
sûr c'est pas parce que je suis d'accord
avec son projet et il ya une certaine
mauvaise foi dans ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure quand même se joignent je
veux dire on ne remet pas en cause le
fait que macro et président en premier
en cause le fait qu'il a n'a pas une
légitimité sur le plan des idées dans
son élection suffisantes pour mener à
bout toutes ces crises à
vos prononceront donc anglais les
abstentionnistes les abstentionnistes
comme c'est comme les absents ils ont
toujours tort il faut bien sûr
l'élection s'est déroulée dans une
courbe à ce que je sais pas ce que je
dis je sinon quand on dit les balayages
parce que au-delà réalité politique
derrière son élection voilà c'est il a
appelé à faire barrage et nous certes un
certain nombre de citoyens oui nous
avons noté au veba râle ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on signe un chèque en blanc pour
5000 et qui pourra mener la politique
qu'il veut il à l'élection il a dit ddd
son discours de vainqueur mais c'était
oui mais je il l'a pas non plus infléchi
son programme non ils disent c'est que
moi je pense que nos projections de ce
corps il ya aussi beaucoup de ne
confirmerai peut-être beaucoup
d'électeurs de emmanuel macron qui
aujourd'hui parce que de la gauche s'est
rassemblée et bien vont vouloir reporter
leurs voix sur nous donc je pense que
cette élection c'est de dire sortons de
l'impasse extrême marché extrêmes
droites et mettons faisons un vrai
barrage à la politique antisociale de
monsieur mâcon cela peut aller dans
votre sens aussi c'est le fait que
d'après un sondage et d une majorité de
français qui veulent qui et
quoi qu'en dise à jouer nous on est dans
un alors il ya des taux politique yadh
louer il ya aussi des temps politique
c'est vrai que c'est que ce temps
politique là étaient occupés est très
bien par jean luc mélenchon et la gauche
il va y avoir maintenant temps politique
plume acronis avec tables de la
nomination d'un premier ministre d'un
gouvernement il va y recevoir ensuite un
temps plus plus rn lorsque alors à
appuyer dans l'eau tout toutes les têtes
de dd zemmourien aider des autres
puisque visiblement elle ne veut pas
d'accord mais elle veut être elle veut
écraser les autres
c'est vrai que les choses peuvent
changer d'ici d'ici le mois de juin
aussi par rapport à l'appréciation des
français non
répondre à la question que vous me posez
des questions alors les modèles model
pour les législatives est en train de
tourner la page pas encore d'un manque
de résultats ni ni de projection alors
je suis d'accord avec vous je remets pas
en cause des sondages on est délinquant
recommandé utilisent et j'ai dit que sur
ce point-là particulier il ya deux
sondages uniquement sur les législatives
pour l'instant donc c'est pas ça ne
suffit pas quand on utilise les sondages
nous on fait la moyenne des sondages et
on a une vision je dirais avec moi de
bien que quand on prend quand on sort un
sondage de son contexte et se sont
passées on sait que
le problème en france et l'autre chose
qui m'a un peu surprise quand même c'est
cette réflexion de
de clémentine autain je crois qui a dit
finalement si on gagne pas au gagnera ou
gagnera dans la rue si on ne gagne pas
les législatives et on sent bien qu'il
ya cette idée là d'une revanche et je
crois que le curseur est pas mis sur la
victoire électorale le curseur vous le
mettez plutôt sur une notion de revanche
sur la victoire on l'aura dans la rue
donc ça c'est un message qui est envoyé
assez forts aux électeurs dire que vous
allez rassembler les abstentionnistes
personne n'est propriétaire des
électeurs personne n'est propriétaire
des votes l'abstention c'est l'élément
le plus compliqué à analyser parce qu il
y a deux dents tellement de motivation à
s'abstenir que finalement on ne peut pas
dresser un idéal type de
l'abstentionniste et puis jouer aussi ce
beau bébé on pourrait même ajouter enfin
à chaque fois les gens revendiquent les
absences 10 pour les partis mais au fond
les abstentionnistes réparties assez
également très souvent la gauche a dit
que l'abstention faisait faisait
les abstentions c'est vrai que là où il
est fort il se
savait très bien fait c'est que
généralement les gens qui sont battus
aux présidentielles leurs électeurs
s'abstiennent ou désactiver là il ya une
volonté de la liberté de faire monter
oui la colère est de mobiliser au
pouvoir des électeurs pardon je
rajouterais un terreau qui excusez moi
oui
mais en fait non pas les de l'abstention
dans cette situation et qui sera le
moteur de cette élection qui sera qui
sera qui sera la clé finalement il sera
l'acte et d'élections qui emportera pour
beaucoup parce qu'on le rappelle plus de
50% d'abstention à une élection dans ça
signifie quand même qu'un électeur sont
plus d'un électeur sur deux qui ne se
déplace pas qui ne qui ne vous écoute
pas je dis vous politique de tous les
deux tout de tout l'est de tous les
côtés donc je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être songer avant de songer à la
stratégie certes pour vous l'idée c'est
d'abord de gagner les élections mais les
lecteurs ce qu'il veut c'est qu'on
tienne les promesses d'un programme et
qu'on applique le programme et les
intentions ne suffisent pas en politique
il faut des réalisations et
votre pouvoir voilà mais y aura beaucoup
de sortants parce que là on parle pas du
pouvoir national on parle d'élection
vous allez forcément voir des sortants
paris vous vous prévalez ici par
ailleurs meilleur tennis dans l'air
enfin le web ou aliéné sortant et 1 et
de non-dits c2 et de l air et des
sortants ils ont un bilan ils ont un
bilan qu'ils pourront mettre en avant
nous un passif comme dire certains et
voilà mais sur ceux qui sont reconduits
sur ce qui se présente à nouveau il ya
des éléments que les électeurs pourront
pourront apprécier je pense qu'il faut
garder les lecteurs au centre au centre
du débat et penser à ce que les lecteurs
va imaginez lorsqu'il va mettre son
bulletin de vote dans l'urne et quelle
image vous lui envoyez quel projet vous
lui envoyez quand on voit ces
dissensions c'est un peu compliqué je
pense que c'est pas secteur pour les
lecteurs et vous avez raison de dire que
tout cela représente pas dans votre
circonscription didier baichère qui est
le député sortant n'est plus candidat il
est remplacé par charles rodwell parce
qu'il a fait grand chose pendant 5 ans
choisir le passage sur motivation chez l
or m je vais je vais vous libérer parce
qu'on se croit que vous avez quelque
chose à vous dire quelque chose annoncée
bon aller voter on va parler attendez on
va parler de la droite de ce qui se
passe à droite et justement je voudrais
vous écoutez ce que répondait le
président du conseil départemental qui
préside aussi aux destinées de l air
dans le département pierre bédier à la
question que vous lui aviez est posée
est ce qu'il y aura des candidats l air
sans alliance avec les maquereaux nist
dans les circonscriptions merci beaucoup
c'est basterra ma vie parce que c'est ce
que nous demande notre formation
politique est claire
pour être tout à fait transparent avec
les yvelinois qui nous regardent je
n'étais pas sur cette ligne politique
moi je pense que ça n'est pas absurde ça
rejoint un peu ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure sur la majorité vit noise je
trouve que dans les grandes difficultés
que connaît la france ça ce n'est pas
absurde de travailler avec le président
réélu je dois dire que le fait qu'il
évoque le soir du premier tour un grand
parti unique a été avec tout le respect
qu'on doit à présent de la république
mail en l'espèce il s'est exprimé en
candidat très grande maladresse parce
que ça donnait un sentiment de
caporalisme qui correspond à aucun
moment au tempérament national
mais moi je pense qu'on a à faire des
choses ensemble alors on va les faire
différemment puisque la ligne qui a été
choisie est donc celle d'une opposition
mais ce sera en tout cas pour ce qu'on
veut nous dans les yvelines une
opposition constructive l'idée ce n'est
pas de s'opposer pour s'opposer on n'est
pas des mélenchonistes des lepénistes
nous on veut s'opposer à un amendement
pour améliorer les réformes nécessaires
pour que la france aille mieux
c'est intéressant parce que c'est donc
de le président du conseil des patrons
présents de l'est elle erre dans les
yvelines et moi j'aurais été plutôt pour
une alliance avec des mâts chronicité
pour recontextualiser cette question que
j'ai posée juste avant on parlait de
l'avenir des républicains et notamment
du fait que dans le département et ben
pierre bédier dirige une majorité
composée à la fois d'élus modem horizons
elle est donc une sorte d'alliance qui
pourrait peut-être l'avenir des
républicains est effectivement pierre
bédier n'est pas contre de travailler
avec emmanuel macron il n'est pas sur la
ligne de jean françois copé
jean-françois copé et plus sur un projet
au gouvernement est une alliance de
gouvernement avec emmanuel macron
l'huile est un peu plus sûres on peut
s'opposer mais pas mais avoir une
opposition constructive elle a
visiblement ce qui est intéressant quand
on regarde la liste des candidats c'est
que finalement
les maquereaux nist enfin ensemble n'ont
pas été beaucoup puisé de ccr macro
compatible fils il ya très peu de cas de
oui soutiennent 2d des candidats et
l'air sortant est ce qu'ils ont pas raté
une
possibilité de prendre encore un peu
d'affaiblir la droite républicaine c'est
peut-être dans l'autre sens que ça n'a
pas marché parce que je crois que
nicolas sarkozy a quand même vivier de
voix là de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
ces vases communicants visiblement les
candidats fallait dlr hésitent à
franchir le pas l'idée quand même de
considérer qu' il y à un implantation
territoriale qui est assez forte il ya
la menace de christian jacob de m 1ère
en face d'un heller dissidents entre
guillemets ou en hiver constructif fois
et l'eire qui passerait sous étiquette
renaissance aux étiquettes ensemble sauf
qu'on sent bien aussi en face enfin j'ai
eu je crois que c'est dans le figaro
dans le jdd un article ou un sous titre
indiqué macro ne plus besoin de la
droite donc on a quand même cette
impression que finalement le père il
vient peut-être plus de la gauche pour
emmanuel macron que de la droite de
cette union de la gauche qui lui pose
quand même une obligation répondre oui
voilà et il y a très peu il y a deux
candidats qui sont partis mais je crois
que guillaume larrivé en dépit de son de
son je dirais de son mouvement qui
titulaire et qui va vers ensemble un
candidat un candidat en marche ensemble
devant lui en fait
on a deux finalement le débauchage file
à l'abandon de son camp peut se faire
mais ça ne signifie pas que l'accueil
soit complètement à bras ouverts donc ça
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose que je dois pas refermé
sur est sûr c'est qu'on sente constance
le grip oui c'est la région aussi avec
les auteurs et puis le point
d'interrogation n'est quelques de karité
point de travail je vois pas faire des
prévisions comme ça mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup annoncent quand même une
nouvelle bérézina pour la droite
républicaine aux législatives vous
disiez que ça pourrait faire un pas
peut-être un parti d'appoint ça va être
ça va être au fond ça le sujet oui
absolument le
je suis d'accord avec
avec véronique et ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est si finalement en termes de
prévisions est ce que le résultat de l
air sera celui du ps d'il ya cinq ans
passés fait que le ps a fortement chuté
et là on voit avec le résultat de
valérie pécresse aux présidentielles on
peut penser qu'effectivement le
le parti des républicains étant est en
perte de vitesse maintenant je suis
encore jeune je ne suis pas devin mais
ce qu'on dit tous depuis le début c'est
que c'est une élection nationale mais
avec un noyau locales et y tiennent
épisode 7 ans dans les dents les
terrifier les électeurs sont je pense
très attachés à leurs députés au fait
que le député vient dans les
circonscriptions travaille avec eux et
au final même si au niveau national le
lait par le parti a fortement chuté on
peut peut-être r peut espérer quand même
conserver un socle assez assez important
du fait de cette implantation locale au
fola la recomposition
attendre à l'après-législatives je pense
qu'elle faisait face à une fois que tout
sera soldé
ça fait juste c'est probablement ce qui
va ce qui manque au parti socialiste
d'avoir eu un peu de peu de courage et
de refuser cette alliance de la carpe et
du lapin et parce que les hôtes
allemands localement ils sont très bien
installés encore et il avait beaucoup de
circonscriptions frab le manceau va et
que là ils ont abandonné pour
je dirais quand on regarde les yvelines
quand même un seul candidat baisse c'est
quand même c'est pour pour le parti qui
est quand même dominé la vème république
à la gauche démagogique pour dire toute
l'existence de ce que je crois que le
foll hidalgo resteront comme le sinistre
dû au corps a définitivement cool et un
le veut pas le foll le fort par nos
librairies olivier faur par leur désir
sur fabiano
non par didier faure et anne hidalgo ce
qu'on voit les deux fossoyeurs du parti
socialiste il s'est brièvement
très brillant enfin n'est vraiment une
carte à jouer pour compléter vos propos
on le voit dans les yvelines notamment
par rapport aux candidats à l'air je
sais pas s'ils vont être sa fille chez
les candidats les républicains pour ces
législatives
on voit qu'il ya quand même énormément
de personnalités locales des films
locaux d olive média frère les maires
alexandre dut blanche pascal thévenot
qui écument alexandra du blanc je
conseille à rayures et que ça leur nuit
blanche beaucoup de conseillers
départementaux avec une implantation
locale via les quais sorte d'aura c'est
un pavé d'açaï et qui sortant ça peut
être ça peut être déterminant notamment
parce que avec cette vision est ce que
cette élection nationale va aussi est
une élection locale et avec des figures
locales finalement qui sont reconnus sur
le territoire parce qu'ils sont souvent
sur le territoire pour défendre b des
politiques publiques départementales des
politiques publiques municipales et donc
ils sont connus des électeurs est-ce que
ça va pas être déterminant dans les
prochains résultats en 2017 on a eu une
vague en marche qui était légitimiste
parce que et puis il y avait l'effet
nouveauté c'était des nouvelles
personnes mais c'est emmanuel mâcon qui
leur avait donné le relais pour
l'emporter là cette année maintenant
attendre c'est des députés sortants et
allègue avoir ce dénommé marc leguay la
liste la liste des candidats mercredi il
ya quand même des se rendit sont connus
maintenant oui sortant et il ya karl
olive maire de poissy candidat dans la
12e et qui siège au conseil
départemental et qui a une vice
présidence
vice président du conseil départemental
détenues par l air plus de députés
maires nuit un peu
ça renforce encore son ancien les
problèmes
de savoir est-ce qu'ils abandonnaient
leur green pour ce faire certains
arbitrages ont quitté la ville ont pris
l'un des enjeux du résultat de 2 jean
sera pour aussi 2023 puisque en 2023 on
aura aussi le troisième tiers des
élections sénatoriales et d'absolu et
donc les députés seront les grands
électeurs des sénateurs donc là aussi ça
aura un impact important pour la
deuxième la deuxième assemblée est l'un
des enjeux justement de faire de ce
quinquennat
des enjeux politiques c'est de savoir si
le parti présidentiel va pouvoir
s'implanter un peu dans le territoire ce
qui n'a pas réussi à faire ni dans les
mairies dit dans les conseils
départementaux ni dans les conseils
régionaux
voilà il est resté un parti national
c'était très intéressant d'ailleurs
parce qu'on a des parties d'un studio
qui marche au plan national le rnd
mercredi sts et qui sont très peu
implanté au niveau local qui reste au
plr c'est intéressant quand même cela
reste que sais je suivais un phénomène
d'abstention parce que c'est une queue
de comète je sais pas vous mais quand
même une dernière question sur le
réflexe légitimiste
qui a toujours joué jusqu'ici
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut être moins fort lors d'une
réélection de président que lors d'une
élection déjà
des pistes sur les législatives c'est à
dire généralement fin jusqu'ici les
français ont toujours donné une majorité
au président qu'il veut des délires
alors est ce qu'ils vont faire ce calcul
déjà c'est un peu un peu compliqué me
semble-t-il est ce qu'ils vont se
laisser attraper dans les mailles de la
colère
de l'efi enfin de la nouvelle union
populaire écologiste et sociale certains
ont parfois tendance à dire socialiste
mais non là les socialistes c'est bien
clair mais les électeurs je pense que la
crise est encore prégnante que la crise
je dirais alors la guerre en ukraine la
crise économique on nous promet on nous
prévoit donc une inflation et il va
atteindre les 5% une croissance qui ne
sera pas au rendez vous donc
même s'il a les fabulistes que vous êtes
parle de stagflation voilà ce que
j'allais dire la banque centrale
européenne et christine lagarde à sa
tête nous dit non non ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'estac façon ça n'a rien à voir
avec les années 70 sauf que la
croissance ralentit la fesse augmente on
peut imaginer que si de moins en moins
de croissance on pourra pas retenir le
chômage encore trop longtemps sauf à
avoir une dépense publique qui va
soutenir qu'il va soutenir l'activité
donc et si on soutient l'activité par la
dépense publique on s'engage dans une
dette qui sera déjà au delà des 113% du
pib et en plus cela les coûteux matériel
qui remonte le chiffrage je crois que
ces dix frappes qui chiffres et cela en
disant si les taux d'intérêts passe à 4
% c'est la folie c'est 80 milliards
supplémentaires donc on a une situation
économique qui s'annonce sous les pires
auspices je pense qu'on peut pas
imaginer pire les français constatent
bien il commence à faire des réserves
enfin j'entendais ce matin la radio les
français achètent mais c'est dans une
peur panique donc là les craintes et là
on fait beaucoup agir sur les craintes
donc les craintes qui sont annoncés
peuvent avoir à nouveau jouer de cet
effet ou à l'irlande ce flag tous
derrière le chef derrière le drapeau est
signifiée par le chef pourrait penser ça
peut peut-être ça peut peut-être jouer
maintenant que l'habitation voilà on a
vu une équipe des cohabitations que l'on
a pu voir elles ont servi des causes de
façon un peu je dirais un peu aléatoire
enfin la première cohabitation n'a pas
n'a pas servi chirac
qui arrive après cinq ans de pouvoir
il sait pas et ce qui est vrai et ce qui
est peut-être rien fait d' aubaine de
sciences politiques c'est intéressant
vous faut on a un pays qui est assez
vieillissant cédera assez vieillissant
c'est pas forcément un électorat qui se
dit tiens je vais prendre des risques à
la législative après avoir voté aux
présidentielles donc le réflexe
légitimiste
il ya comme une chose on revenir vous
que votre question est une chose qui est
étonnant c'est d'abord pourquoi est-ce
qu emmanuel macron à décaler les
élections législatives ce qui est assez
aberrant parce que sa revanche ce que
vous dites est ce qu'ils ont en effet
tous j après la présidentielle
normalement les élections législatives
sont beaucoup plus proches de l'élection
présidentielle que là il a reculé de 15
jours ou trois semaines ce qui est dans
une once et bien qu'à plus des alliances
mais là ça rallonge le temps de façon
assez bizarre ça c'est une première
chose de personne je suis pas peut-être
une explication sur cette idée du
rallongement qu'ils allaient qui a
surpris tout le monde du délai et puis
deuxième chose c'est que on gagne ou on
perd 1-0 éventuellement une élection
législative aussi avec un premier
ministre qui est ici qui est censé
emmené et là il va y avoir bientôt
ballon c'est pas sexy macron joue à
masquer singer il est là il le fait
connais mais je vous le dirai pas qui
dans le costume du premier ministre on
verra je vous donne des indices en fin
mai et ce alors si c'est ridicule je
reparle de ce qu'elle disait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'il ya des temps
politique si y'a qu'la on a mis un temps
politique très occupée par la gauche et
par mélenchon
marine le pen pour l'instant elle est
totalement absente elle va revenir ça va
aussi changer un peu la bonne c'est à
dire que là on entend que mélenchon mais
on a pu entendre que lui est venue et
vas y voit là et va y avoir maintenant
le temps du nouveau gouvernement du
nouveau premier ministre donc c'est vrai
que tout ça va peut aussi équilibrer les
choses un peu différentes quand les
sondages d'aujourd'hui sont sur le tombé
le sioniste si je peux dire ce qui se
passe en ce moment avec mélenchon ça
rappelle un peu ce qui s'est passé et
xénon pour
toujours et ça tout ça ne fait plus que
de ça il y avait plus que zemmour plus
personne d'exister et puis là maintenant
on ne parle plus que de mélenchon mais
effectivement heureusement qu'on va
passer à autre chose non mais de quelle
manière qu'on attendait d'eux nommé son
premier ministre pour voir aussi comment
des autres partis politiques s'organiser
pour savoir s'il doit aller chercher un
premier ministre plutôt à gauche ou
plutôt à droite aussi peut-être c'était
ce que je cherchais à gauche c'est
vraiment la compétition je pense que
malgré ses dires il faudra un premier
ministre parce qu'on entendait parler du
monde de ségolène royal par et qui lui
sont fidèles
c'est toi c'est pas possible tout ça on
a le temps
d'ici les 12 et 19 juin
merci infiniment
0 merci beaucoup à faire le mode la civi
diot charles jani et nicolas landry et
puis merci à sébastien de rabat son
candidat dans la première huit téléfilms
c'est logique avec ce qui se passe au
niveau national absolument merci à tous
bienvenue et à bientôt mais trouve un
prochain numéro paf
[Musique]